- On this episode, I give
the most compelling reason
for you to finally comment.
(upbeat hip-hop music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is a 180 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Geez we've not been putting these out
at any kind of regular pace
and it's kind of pissing me off
and I'm sure it's pissing
you all off as well.
I'm sorry about that.
It has been busy with
VaynerMedia and Book World
and DailyVee.
We kind of made a commitment
a couple weeks ago
DRock and I of two daily Vee's
and two #AskGaryVee's
per week is kind of what
we're aspiring to do.
It feels super unnatural.
We like god, we've like
done hardly any shows
India, I don't even, I
almost called you Africa
because I don't even remember your name.
- You don't know who I am.
- You know like I don't
even know who you are
anymore, India.
I don't know who you are.
Guys and all of you who love the show
I want to give you huge daps,
thanks for being patient.
I'm super excited about
doing the show today.
I'm here tomorrow, I don't
see it in my calendar,
not in my calendar, right?
- [DRock] No.
- I think I may try to
sneak one in tomorrow too
because I just need it and
thank you for everybody
that's been supporting the book.
This would be a great time to buy the book
if you haven't yet, I really need it,
and if you don't know about Super8
let's link that up in right here,
and let's also link that up on Facebook
and YouTube copy.
Super8 big event, February
23rd, 10 to 6 pm eastern,
right in, oh no, are we
doing it at the court?
No we're going to do it here right?
We're going to do it right here.
A telethon, buy eight
books, lottery ticket,
come to New York, see me,
spend an hour with me,
India let's, see I don't even
know how to do this anymore.
Let's...
- We're off our game.
- Let's get into the show.
I'm fired up today, I've got good energy.
- [India] You are.
- I'm excited, Facebook live what's up?
- I'm just getting it up so.
- All right, let's go.
- [India] Okay the first one,
I've practiced saying this,
it's a Welsh word.
- Go ahead.
- [India] I think it's
sunerk, but I'm not sure.
- Sunerk.
- [India] Sunerk, yeah.
- Okay, sunerk, okay.
- [Voiceover] TrefnantGolf
asks, "No new twitter users
"registered between October
and Christmas last year.
"Thoughts?"
- It's not no new
Twitter users, it's a net loss.
- [India] Well thoughts on that?
- Bad.
I think we're working on
a very big Twitter piece.
- [India] Yes.
- When is that going to be done?
- [India] Tomorrow, Monday
morning at the latest
and then we'll use this answer.
- Oh we will use this answer.
Okay interesting.
It's very meta up in here in 180.
You know I think, look, I've
been on this kick for awhile.
You'll see tomorrow
afternoon, most likely Monday
because I know how these guys roll,
we'll put together a very big piece
like we did with Snapchat.
Thank you for everybody who's shared that.
Actually link that up.
If you haven't read the
manifesto for Snapchat
it was incredible, great work by the team.
We've got one coming out for Twitter.
We want to do these big signature pieces
kind of fun cover
stories more for the blog
and for you guys.
Also big shout out to everybody.
So many people emailing me thankful
for the new VIP video only content.
We've finally, we've finally figured out
how to make my email service much more
valuable to people and I'm killing DRock.
I feel like seven years of
angst to deliver on these videos
that's why it's going so well.
So if you're not signed
up for the newsletter,
that's another (expletive) right hook.
Actually, let's just
title this 180 right hook.
Books, VIP emails, sign up for everything.
Facebook if you're watching,
sign up for my YouTube,
subscribe, YouTube, sign up for Facebook.
Da, da, da, da.
Look Twitter's struggling,
people don't understand it,
it's losing attention,
Instagram, and Snapchat emerged
as major attention grabbers
within mobile devices
and I think of all, give me this phone,
I think of all of my, this
is what I think about.
I think this is the television
and the TV is the radio
and it's 1965.
That's what I think.
I think this is the television 1965
and TV is the radio.
There's a lot of people
that still think the radio
in 1965 is the place to advertise
and spend your time and energy.
I don't believe that to be true anymore.
I think this is the number one device
and I think that YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram,
and Snapchat are ABC, NBC, and CBS.
That's what I think's
happening with Twitter.
Think of Twitter as MTV.
10 years ago it was
there and think about me
Gary Vee being, being
one of the hit shows,
Remote Control, whoa I'm very old.
Sorry I'm fucking old.
You know, Jersey Shore, think of me,
Gary Vee on Twitter as I'm Jersey Shore,
Twitter's MTV, this is the television.
What I think has happened
to Twitter is that Snapchat
and Instagram have now become ESPN,
have now become the hot network
and so that's what I think is happening
to everybody right this second on Twitter.
The reason it's not growing is because
that network is not
growing on the television
and I'm excited though because much like
how networks got turned around,
the way that NBC, the way that
CBS went from fourth place
to first place was they
brought in new executives
who did better job programming,
and so Jack Dorsey's now in place.
He'll be making a lot of changes
and if those changes work,
Twitter can rise but
we've not seen it in tech.
MySpace wasn't able to
rejuvenate itself, right?
We saw it a little bit with Facebook.
There was a lull for
a second with Facebook
and then they made a lot of good tweaks
and it like just completely
became the establishment.
I am so intrigued by seeing
what's going to happen
but I think Twitter is dealing with what
they're dealing with.
My ultimate thoughts are,
it's getting what it deserved.
They didn't ideate the product
for a long period of time
and they're paying the price.
- [Voiceover] Littleoceandrop
asks, "How can I use a diploma
"and years of experience
if they are in a field
"I don't currently want to work in?"
- LOD, there's a lot of things you can do.
You can use your career and your diploma
as a proxy to people and show them that
you're able to accomplish things
that you have set your goals out to do
while acknowledging that
you are now shifting
those goals in your life.
The truth is, nobody's
going to penalize you
for making a shift into a new arena.
You just have to convince
that decision maker
that all the skills, and drive, and talent
that you deployed there are going to be
acceptable in this new world.
You know, let's just say for example that
you made your entire career living in
the wine business as a merchant
and then decided that you wanted to run
one of Madison Avenue's most premiere
digital shops.
That would take some convincing
and you do that by
convincing and then you do it
by doing.
And so, much like many people have had
different careers and they've gone from,
much like, you know what,
you're like the Rock.
The Rock was a successful wrestler,
but we didn't think he was going to be
a superstar movie actor until he did it.
So in the beginning he had to convince
decision makers, directors, producers,
agents, the market, that he was capable,
and then you get your at bats.
Marky Mark is now one
of the great successful
entrepreneur people, his
name is Mark Wahlberg,
he's a superstar, he's a businessman.
We didn't think Marky Mark
was going to cross over.
Justin Timberlake was in a boy band
with some curly ass hair.
We didn't think he'd be
one of the great musicians
of our generation or some didn't.
So I would say that it's very easy,
you just have to think about this.
I think it's going to
be quite easy for you
to convince somebody to give you a job
or give you money for your start up.
I think the next part's
way more interesting.
Can you actually do it?
Because everything's built against that.
Just because you want to
go into something else
doesn't mean you'll be successful
so if you feel confident and assured
that you can do it, don't worry about
convincing everybody,
just convince somebody
because then you're on the record.
Just to convince one person
that you can make videos
and then you're on the
record and the either
you make them and they're
good, or you make them
and they're shit.
That may be a good piece, India.
- I was just about to say
I'm going to make you one.
- [Gary] Convincing one person.
- Mmmh-hmm, I like the segway into hey,
I did that.
- I did.
- [India] Guess what?
- You didn't see me
coming with that right,
because it's such in the background right?
Like you just know it's true.
Like that was why it was a fun recall.
It's not the, like a lot
of people didn't think
I was going to use
myself as a proxy because
it's now accepted that I
did it, but at the time
when I made the switch,
people were very cynical.
Okay, Twitter Boy, running an agency
against all these real
agencies, Widen Kenedy
and OMD, these are real companies.
These are billion dollar, Madison Avenue,
Mad Men Companies and I was
like fuck those companies.
And either I was going
to be too egotistical
and flop and full of shit or
I was going to be what I am,
a fucking beast.
- Like you do the high school
that's all like on Fern
and then have bad men
being like hey Twitter Boy,
pushing you.
- And that's what it was.
It's like hey Twitter
Boy, I think Business Week
even wrote like hey Twitter Boy.
- Start with clickgear clothing.
- Let's do it clickgear.
- Hey, what's up Gary,
Michael Anthony here.
I'm the creator of clickgear clothing
and I have a question for you.
Over the course of the
last year I've spent
all my efforts trying to grow a community
of photographers around my brand
but I've realized in order
to take it to the next level
I have to find a partner or an investor,
but the problem is I have
this defensive wall up
about asking for help.
It's just not the way I was raised.
My question is, how do
you get past that man?
How do you take down that wall and say,
hey, you know what, I need help,
and then reach out to people?
I really appreciate your thoughts on this,
thank you so much.
- That was so well done.
Let's have more of that.
You know we haven't done this right hook
in a while, ask questions.
There's so many of you
that are not asking.
I love when people Tweet
like this is my eighth time
getting on the show.
You're right because you're
a beast, also and you just
keep asking, yet the 98%
of you have never asked
a question once.
Use the hashtag on the
comments in YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter, or Instagram because
fuck it, I'll give you
every option to get your questions in.
I like to get some new people in here.
Also, I like what we did with Snapchat.
Send me some questions and I'll hand you
my phone tomorrow and
you'll just go through
some of the video questions
and maybe we'll download
them or what have you.
Oh actually, that's'
right, ask your question
on Snapchat to me
directly, then download it
because you can, and then Tweet it.
I'd like to get some more
Snapchat visuals in the show
since we're on it.
- [India] And you can learn how
to download in the article.
- In you can learn how to
download in our article.
My man, first and
foremost, I'm kind of bored
by this question and let me tell you why.
You just let your guard down
You are scared to ask for, and I get it
because I also don't like asking for help
so I really connected with you by the way
in the black and white, it was just
a great video.
You just did.
You just put yourself out
there to 100,000 people.
You just owned it so you're good, really.
You're good, you've now
put yourself out there.
My comment to you is go into YouTube
and Facebook right now and leave a comment
so the other homies of this community
can find you to say what you're missing.
Is it the financial part, is
it the organizational part,
like why don't you come,
be like yo that's me,
because I don't know your name.
Do you know his name?
- [India] I don't know his name.
- Got it, but everyone
will know who you are
and just be like here are
the six things I want.
Guys, the dirty little secret about
The #AskGaryVee Show and DailyVee
is if you become part of
the community, you will win.
Let me explain.
Watching each of you
biz-dev with each other
in my comments section,
this silent majority
that watch the show and
yeah I'm trying to bring
you out lurkers today.
The silent majority of you
are making a huge mistake
just commenting and saying
first time commenter,
in this episode like
what you've been doing,
or answer the question of
the day that I come up with,
or what have you, we'll
put you in the ecosystem
for other people saying hey,
because there's a couple
of extraverts out there.
So to you my man directly,
I really need you to like
list what you're shortcomings are.
I have a funny feeling 15
people are going to respond
and say they've got those strengths
and you might find your partner right in
my comments section.
For the rest of you,
get in this community.
- [Voiceover] Serena asks,
"You travel so much -
"what are your tricks and
tips for overcoming jet lag?"
- I don't have a trick.
I don't know what's happening.
It's called enormously lucky DNA.
I think my brain can out
will a lot of things.
I think when I get going, I don't know,
I've just got it like that.
I've got a lot of natural energy.
I showed up on some people's podcasts
over the last couple
days and a lot of people
leave comments like this guy's on drugs.
So I'm super high energy.
I get it, it's so crazy, I've never even
smoked a cigarette.
You know like so it's crazy how lucky I am
with my natural adrenaline.
What?
- It is crazy.
It's crazy just like being
around you, it's real.
Like that's not just
when you're on the show
or like on DailyVee.
- Right and it's real and it's long.
It's real, sustained, for 18 hours a day,
every day, every month, every year.
Yeah Mike was even saying
to me, I landed from
I did the red eye, and I landed,
and then we worked out yesterday and I had
the best workout I've ever had like,
my energy, he was just literally like
how the fuck do you never crash?
We're super behind Matt.
- [India] Last one.
- We're okay?
I get it, when do I have to leave?
Okay cool, all right, we'll wrap up soon.
James, we're here for
the all hands on right?
Why don't I do?
Yeah exactly, I can do it with him then.
I don't want to hold him up.
Awesome.
All right.
- [India] Last one from Caleb.
- Caleb, oh this kid.
- [India] Yeah.
- Hey Gary, Caleb Maddix
here and my question is
if the next 30 seconds
of The #AskGaryVee Show
was broadcasted to all
seven billion people
on this planet, what would you say?
Thank you so much for
answering my question.
By the way, I'm pumped
to be speaking with you
in Sydney, Australia.
It's going to be off the charts.
- The charts, the charts.
Caleb, what would I say?
That's a really good question.
Now Caleb, this is
something you don't know.
I once, four and a half years ago explored
and was willing to put up my own money
for a Superbowl commercial
and in the commercial
it was going to say, so I
guess this is I probably
already answered this, four years ago,
five years ago, before,
maybe six years ago.
Six years ago, about six years ago,
I tried to buy a Superbowl commercial
for two million dollars,
my own personal money
like pretty much my liquid at the time
and I was going to make
a commercial that says
hey America, it's me
Gary and I really want
to be your friend and I'm not kidding.
I basically want to know you.
I'm into wine, I'm into business,
I need to know you, here's my handle.
It's Twitter @GaryVee and
I'm going to be sitting
right now answering all
of you, every one of you.
So that's what I would probably do.
I would probably replicate, and by the way
the end of the story was
I had the money for that
but for all you media
buyers, you knew this
I didn't know it at the
time, if you try to buy
at the Superbowl, Fox or CBS or NBC
makes you buy another
20 million dollars worth
of commercials around the
year to even get access
to pay two million.
That I didn't have and so
Caleb and everybody else,
what I would do is I would
just create a context point
to let America know that I'm a listener
for all the, you know it's funny.
I got a lot of feedback
by showing up on a bunch
of podcasts the last
couple days and by asking,
I've been asking a lot
how did you first feel
about me when the truth is, I don't make
a good impression with
most people at first
because I curse and because I have ego.
What they don't know is that I equally
have humility.
That I equally am not
a snake oil salesman.
That I'm equally a tremendously good dude.
So there's a very ironic thing with me,
I'm not as big as I could be followers,
selling books, impact on the world because
of the way I come out the gate.
With that energy, with
that competition love,
with that bravado and I know that,
yet I don't change because I think
authenticity will always win.
I'd rather, the amount of people that said
they came around to me
in the comment section,
I don't know if you guys
read the Facebook on this
or the Instagram like,
I first didn't like you
but then I kept hearing about you.
I watched the second video, a third,
now I watch The #AskGaryVee Show,
I really go to know you.
That's why #AskGaryVee's been big for me.
You've gotten to know me
a lot better with this
and DailyVee and so that's
what I would do Caleb.
I would just try to
establish that I'm a listener
and I'd say hey, what do
you want to talk about,
I'm here to answer
questions, so that's what
I would do.
That's it?
- [India] That's it.
- Great, I'm going to throw
Caleb's question at you
because good job 14 year old hustler.
That's a good quesiton.
What would you do if you had
all of America's attention
for 30 seconds during a Superbowl spot?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(upbeat hip hop music)